the metrics that we have are not wrong
they're just incomplete right the way
the standard metrics that we have to
measure our own success in our company's
profits and where revenues you better
whatever you want to use and the
standard metrics we use to measure our
own wealth there's nothing wrong with
those they're just incomplete that's
like saying you know when I chose to
marry her she's really good-looking
important and you see a good person
should she bring the best out in me you
know how is she in times of stress like
will she look after me will I look after
her will she let me help her you know in
other words there's more to it and it's
the same for businesses so what I'm what
I'm learning to do is to understand
those balancing metrics so I'm now very
interested in things like momentum right
where I want to measure momentum as much
as I want to measure accomplishment or
sheer numbers so for example the
traditional way in which we measure this
is this is really funny this is an
inside joke you won't get can I have
that pad if you still have it back there
please or not never mind the traditional
there was a whole debate before I don't
need the pad I don't need the patent
they said we'll keep it here in case you
need it I'm like no I don't need it now
I need it anyway I'll just do a visual
thing so the way we traditionally
measure success is we give someone a
goal right we say meet this financial
goal and then what we do is
you're the best so here's what we do we
give somebody a financial goal we say
hit that goal right and what we do is we
don't we don't know how they got there
right they beg borrow and steal the
morale and their team is if they're
doing well it's high when they're doing
badly it's really low they can't hold on
to employees or team members they keep
quitting or getting fired and it's kind
of a mad dash and then on the right day
on the right time they hit the goal and
we give that person a bonus there's
another person who's building a team
morale is really good all the time
whether it's good times are bad
performances not crazy highs or lows
it's just the steady growth the team
gets along great and at the end of the
financial year that's where they end up
and they miss their goal we don't give
that person a bonus
and so what I'm starting to pay
attention to is momentum right and how
we got somewhere clearly clearly this
person's going to hit their goal in 16
months or 17 months but to the rest of
the organization we told them don't do
this we told the rest of the
organization do this so what ends up
happening is we are incentivizing
behavior that's actually bad for the
organization and bad for the team
because we make this the end-all be-all
so what I'm considering is not just were
they able to hit the goal but how how is
the momentum and in reality I want not
to give this person a bonus and I want
to give this person a bonus because
whatever they're doing I want them to do
more of that because in long term this
is way more valuable to my company than
this and it's same with my own life like
I'm starting to think in terms of
momentum so it doesn't I don't really
care what my book sales are I genuinely
don't care what I care about
does it keep selling because what that
means is my message is relevant enough
that there's still demand for it with no
marketing I'm not out there Hawking it
because I know if I turn up the
marketing dial I'll see the numbers go
up I want to see can it sustain itself
so so unlike a lot of other people in my
business you can become an Amazon number
one bestseller it's really easy you get
all of your friends to buy the book in
the same hour because the algorithm
recalculates every hour and you can
launch your own little self-published
book get all four into bed and in your
category you'll be number one and for
the rest of your life you're a number
one Amazon bestseller
you can hire a company to make you a New
York Times best seller and you only need
to make the New York Times best seller
list once one week and for the rest of
your life you're a New York Times
bestselling author it's all [ __ ]
or get all your friends to give you five
stars on Amazon you've got a five-star
book and you don't you sell one book a
year I don't have any I don't ask any
friends to write any Amazon reviews for
me I don't ask anybody to buy a book at
a certain time I've never hired a
company to make me a New York Times best
seller and the reason is because I
actually want to know I actually want to
know is that really a four and a half
star book is that really a two and a
half star book has I have I offered the
world something of value I actually want
to read the valuable criticisms because
I actually care about my long game I
want to know that the value that I'm
providing can sustain without me pushing
it so in my own personal life and in my
business I'm looking for new ways to
understand and measure momentum and I'll
add one other thing because I can't help
myself
I give long answers plus I just think
this is really interesting so I work
with the Navy I've worked with the Navy
SEALs and I asked them like who do you
how do you pick like the guys that go on
SEAL Team 6 right because they're the
best of the best the best the best and
they drew it they drew it graph from me
and on one side they drew they wrote the
word for performance and on the other
side they were they wrote the word trust
the way they define the terms is
performance on the battlefield and
performance off the battlefield so this
is your skills this is did you make your
quarterly earnings whatever however want
to translate it right performance its
traditional this is how are you off the
battlefield what kind of person are you
the way they put it is I may trust you
with my life but do I trust you with my
money and my wife
they're seals this is what they told me
nobody wants this person the low
performer of low trust of course of
course
everybody wants this person the high
performer of high trust of course what
they learned is that this person the
high performer of low trust is a toxic
leader and a toxic team member and they
would rather have a medium performer of
high trust sometimes even a low
performer of high trust it's a relative
scale over this person this is the
highest performing organization on the
planet and this person is more important
than than this person and the problem in
business is we have lopsided metrics we
have a million-in-one metrics to measure
someone's performance and negligible to
no metrics to measure someone's
trustworthiness and so what we end up
doing is promoting or bonusing toxicity
in our businesses which is bad for the
long game because it eventually destroys
the whole organization the irony is it's
unbelievably easy to find these people
go to any team and say who's the [ __ ]
and melt
they will all point to the same person
equally if you go to any team and say
who do you trust more than anybody else
who's always got your back and when the
chips are down they will be there with
you
they will also all point to the same
person it's the best gifted natural
leader who's getting who's creating an
environment for everybody else to
succeed and they may not be your most
individual highest performer but that
person you better keep them on your team
[Music]